tell me about the outfit girl this is
hot it's Fendi clearly you like one word
it's it's aggressive where the muscle
are you guys where does the body a very
well-dressed security are they're really
cute how does it feel being here anybody
you're excited to meet tonight what is
it that's active not just your security
but your height men as well they are my
[Music]
coordinate sunglasses no that's just not
just hive minded weird how are you gonna
feel if you win I'll probably faint do
you have a speech no we don't want you
to faint we don't want that either
III really think I'm just here for a fun
time yeah okay happens we'll catch it
I'll make one of them go out for me and
we're gonna play our game with you guys
popcorn pop quiz
pickle question and answer for us I love
games is there a movie remember making
it how stupid you were younger I got
that best kiss afford what movie did you
make out soon that's good Oh Oh scary
movie 3 okay
comedy horror I'm that guy that's
usually in the movie that's not kill
hold off one second we're students are
filming of the craft it's not a movie
but the office the show the office
[Music]
because it's like you can jump right
back in exact white still being Dwight
Dwight is still being Joyce what's up
next for the show for your show a lot of
crazytown a lot of craziness we were
filming until about 4:00 a.m. today
in Vancouver nonetheless and died here
it's full of a lot of spirit that's why
she sounds so raspy because it is why I
sound like I've been smoking since I was
six upping the ante majorly how so
yes how your character yeah I mean I
can't spoil much but yeah I have been in
a lot of different makeup looks so I
could say that much yeah there's a lots
lots of new prosthetics lots of cool
demons that's carrier oh yeah I feel
like every house in the show just goes
up that extra notch a new characters you
meet new characters to play some fun new
new people
[Music]